merci je passe la parole à présent
monsieur jean françois husson pour le
groupe ump
oui monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'énergie est un des sujets
fondateur de l'union européenne que ce
soit au travers de la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier ou
de la communauté européenne de l'énergie
atomique
cela répondait à cette belle ambition de
jean monnet pour construire l'europe je
cite m les moyens de la guerre au
service de la paix l'énergie est
aujourd'hui encore un enjeu majeur du
dessein européen
que ce soit à travers la dépendance
énergétique les échanges commerciaux
hors communauté européenne
la question de la sécurité des
approvisionnements ou des énergies
renouvelables
les défis sont nombreux l europe doit
dès maintenant se préparer à changer en
profondeur la manière dont elles
produits consomment et transporte
l'énergie pour cela les pays doivent
agir de manière cohérente mais où est la
cohérence dans votre politique
la société d'état edf vient de remporter
un contrat remarquable en grande
bretagne pour construire deux paires
développer le nucléaire
en accord avec le gouvernement français
actionnaire d'edf
serait-il bon pour la grande bretagne
mais pas pour la france concernant les
hydrocarbures de schiste
la france se prive aujourd'hui du droit
même d'explorer et dans le même temps
gdf suez à 34% propriété de l'état
acquiert une participation dans 13
permis d'exploration en grande-bretagne
incohérences ou hypocrisie
la future loi de programmation sur
l'énergie annoncée initialement pour mi
2013 devrait être adopté pour fin 2014
incohérences ou indécision l'énergie est
un des points forts de notre industrie
l'efficacité énergétique un pilier d'une
croissance plus vertueuses et créatrice
d'emplois
quels sont vos objectifs votre volonté
votre cap
s'agit-il d'être otage d'une composante
de votre majorité bien fragile
la france enfin vise les trois fois 20
pour 2020 mais que fait-on concrètement
pour les atteindre il n'a qu'à voir ce
qui se passe avec la politique les
atermoiements aujourd'hui pour les
certificats d'économie d'énergie
incohérence indécision atermoiements
dans cette cacophonie quelle peut être
la contribution de la france à la
politique énergétique européenne
merci monsieur le ministre philippe
martin président monsieur sénateurs us
ont merci de me donner finalement la
possibilité de vous dire deux trois mots
sur la logique de la politique qui est
menée parce que la logique de
l'immobilisme celle de ne rien faire
sera celle qui abouti car en matière
énergétique au renchérissement sans fin
du coût de l'énergie à une facture
énergétique porté par les ménages qui
sera insupportable et qui ruinera la
compétitivité des entreprises
la politique que vous avez menées qui
est celle de ne jamais traiter la
question de l'énergie de ne jamais osé
faire un débat national sur la
transition énergétique
comme nous l'avons fait de vouloir
rénover notre mix énergétique de pas
simplement laisser au fil de l'eau les
énergies se renchérir avec des
augmentations sans fin pour les ménages
et pour les entreprises eh bien nous
nous voulons faire le contraire nous
nous voulons que l'état soit stratège
nous nous voulons effectivement une
politique de transition énergétique qui
fasse que les énergies renouvelables
soient beaucoup plus forte
et s'agissant des gaz de schiste et
cette loi du 2 2 2011 votée à
l'initiative de votre excellent confrère
de l'ump monsieur jacob puisque c'est
quand même bien lui qui aujourd'hui nous
traitent d'obscurantistes alors que
c'est lui qui a fait cette loi
eh bien je me félicite crois que le
conseil constitutionnel ait donné raison
en droit et sur la forme à cette loi qui
interdit d'aller encore un peu plus vers
des énergies fossiles dont nous n'avons
pas besoin il faut changer d'ère
monsieur husson et changer d'air ça
n'est pas complaire à une formation
politique c'est penser au pays
penser aux générations futures et la
politique du gouvernement c'est celle
qui justement prépare à l'avenir des
générations futures
merci alors monsieur jean françois
husson oui monsieur le ministre
j'entends le procès en immobilisme et au
fait que vos prédécesseurs n'aurait rien
fait dieu merci et les uns les autres
ont pu constater notamment que les
effets des différentes lois grenelle se
font aujourd'hui sentir et ressentir
voilà ça a été souvent souligné
donc premier élément deuxième élément
j'ai été surpris et je me suis interrogé
quand vous avez déclaré tout à l'heure
que l'énergie était à l'ordre du jour de
l'agenda européen sur la proposition et
grâce au présent république
écoutez puisse-t-il en sortir cette fois
des décisions fortes et concrètes pour
notre avenir et enfin puisque je suis
sur le concret sur les certificats
d'économie d'énergie qui répondent aux
trois fois 20 je vous même monsieur le
ministre je vous demande pardon de bien
vouloir intervenir auprès du pôle
national parce qu'il est des territoires
notamment le mien le goff et celle de
celui dont je suis élu sur le grand
nancy où plus de mille aujourd'hui
dossiers de particuliers ou
d'entreprises attendent attendent d'être
traités
c'est aujourd'hui ressenti comme étant
inacceptable inadmissible
je compte donc sur votre prompte et
efficace intervention très bien mes
chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h pour la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi pour
l'accès au logement et à l'urbanisme
rénover la séance est suspendue